l'heure du choix hollande sarkozy ou
peut-être du non choix approche pour
françois bayrou est loin d'apparaître
cette fois comme le troisième homme de
la campagne présidentielle le candidat
centriste qui se sont plaints de force
pour le premier tour tient t-il encore
les clés du second tour philippe
douste-blazy bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous vous avez rallié
françois bayrou au début de cette année
en réaction à la dérive droitière de
l'ump à vivre écrit dans le monde dont
voulais tu tombes datent un des
cofondateurs il faut le rappeler
vous avez donc rejoint le candidat
centriste qui est à la peine cette année
alors que va-t-il décider dimanche soir
eh bien c'est samir tounsi de l' agence
france-presse
qui tentera tout à l'heure d'obtenir une
réponse
et perrine tarneaud de public sénat vous
interrogera sur votre retour bas dans le
marigot français et j'ai envie de dire
alors que vous suivez les grands
chantiers de la solidarité mondiale
notamment à l'onu malgré sa popularité
donc malgré sa manière directe d'évoquer
les problèmes de la france la dette les
déficits malgré à un projet qui est bâti
sur une perspective de croissance
raisonnable 1% pour 2013 c'est le
chiffre qui était confirmé il ya
quelques jours par le fmi françois
bayrou patine donc pourquoi selon vous
d'abord parce qu'il dit la vérité et que
il a choisi depuis le début de dire les
vérités vous venez de de rappeler une
chose importante lorsque on dit on va
diminuer les déficits publics il faut
partir sur une hypothèse de croissance
lui les parties sur exactement
l'hypothèse de croissance que vous venez
de rappeler celle du fmi quand vous
voyez nicolas sarkozy ou françois
hollande
cette cette année mais ensuite 2 puis
deux et demi c'est à dire que c'est
totalement évidemment
faux et mensonger évidemment vous pouvez
faire énormément de promesses si vous
avez une croissance entre 1 7 et 2 et
demi pour cent et donc je crois que le
fait d'avoir dit la vérité parce que
c'est votre question pourquoi il ne
dépasse pas en définitive les les 13 ou
14% 2013 non moi je pense que ça monte
d'accord bon mais je pense que ça montre
vraiment mais on va en parler après mais
indiscutablement c'est pas comme en 2007
donc je crois que c'est parce que il dit
la vérité la vérité n'est pas toujours
facile à entendre et je crois qu'on a
besoin aujourd'hui d'hommes politiques
qui disent la vérité un jour on fait
comme si la crise économique n'existait
pas c'est complètement dingue c'est pas
tout à fait vrai mais candidats on parle
ces messieurs avec 2% de croissance moi
je peux vous pas d'accord c'est comme
celà monolithe il dit la vérité françois
bayrou mais pourtant il s'est trompé
parce qu'il misait sur un effondrement
de nicolas sarkozy or le président
sortant est au coude à coude dans les
sondages avec françois hollande cas vous
voyez aujourd'hui certains sondages par
rapport à ceux de la semaine dernière
il ya une diminution très importante du
président sarkozy quant au second tour
c'est maintenant quelque chose qui
pratiquement sur moi bien qui est très
très très difficile pour lui de gagner
cette élection présidentielle et donc on
voit bien aussi que pendant ce temps
françois bayrou est temps de monter moi
je pense que le premier tour le 22 avril
2012 sera un tour avec une énorme
surprise qui pourrait préfigurer d'un
nouveau paysage politique français
comment est-ce que vous expliquer alors
le recul de nicolas sarkozy cette fois
ci je crois que l'un comme l'autre
les verts font une faute politique
majeure je parle de nicolas sarkozy de
françois hollande c'est que ils ne
disent pas que la crise économique est
devant nous nicolas sarkozy a même dit
qu'il qu'elle était derrière nous que
c'est terminé
ils ont dit tous les deux que on pouvait
dépenser plus alors nicolas sarkozy
c'est 18 milliards je crois par an et
françois hollande c'est tenez vous bien
entre 30 et 32 milliards
d'euros de plus par an avec un déficit
déjà 2 100 milliards par an donc je
crois que là c'est pas sérieux
attention annoncé évidemment des
perspectives de recettes accrue avec
notamment une fiscalité plus élevée là
je voudrais pas me je voudrais pas me
répéter mais avec une croissance qui est
qu'il faut ça colle donc tout ça
évidemment ne va pas on va me seront
démentis selon vous par les faire
ailleurs d'ailleurs en gommant françois
hollande a commencé à dire je vais faire
une audite alors qu'un homme politique
disait faire un audit en arrivant j'ai
trouvé ça veut dire sang et des larmes
ça je ne crois pas justement face au
pérou c'est ça qui nous parle qui me
plaît dans son programme c'est que c'est
d'une part un effet 50 milliards de 18,2
d'économies et 50 milliards de recettes
supplémentaires mais aussi s'est
relancée par la croissance par la
consommation c'est à dire par une
augmentation des emplois en france parce
que il n'est pas écrit que l'industrie
française doit disparaître car oui
parlons encore de nicolas sarkozy il est
lâché par des personnalités aujourd'hui
c'est ce que françois bayrou très en
verve et évoque à sous le nom de
transhumants souvient de la marge d'ebit
nous parce que nous sommes des pyrénées
novelli on voit bien tous les tous les
ans un de la vallée à la montre et
montagne à la vallée on voit bien passé
tous ces moutons ce sont les ralliés de
la 25e heure qu'est-ce que vous inspire
justement ses ministres d'ouverture qui
vont donc bas à bonnes sources pensent
que les loups distille oui d'abord je
crois qu'ils vont être déçus parce que
d'après ce que j'ai compris françois
hollande a dit qu' il ne ferait pas
d'ouverture c'est pas la bonne soupe
alors c'est pas si vous qui le dites
en tout cas mais en tout cas moi je
pensais que quand on ne peut pas faire
confiance à des gens qui sont à la fois
à droite à gauche au centre et qui ne
savent pas très bien et giroud ou esso
enfin il indique le sens du vent oui
mais toujours des gens il faut il n'ya
pas non plus de personnalité politique
majeure et mousse entendait quand même
parmi celles ci les plaintes de
membre éminent de la majorité parfois
qui semble régler un compte personnel
avec nicolas sarkozy un pour des
échanges violents le mot a été utilisé
par exemple par la sénatrice ump chantal
jouanno non ce que je crois vous qui
connaissez nicolas cela me surprend non
ce que je crois c'est que lorsque j'ai
fait l'ump avec alain juppé et jacques
chirac
j'ai cru vraiment qu'on pouvait faire un
parti de centre droit j'ai cru que
c'était possible
voilà et nicolas sarkozy a totalement
assumé d'ailleurs mais moi je respecte
ce choix
ce n'est pas le mien c'est tout de faire
carrément un virage très à droite pour
aller chercher les électeurs du front
national ça avait marché en 2007
ça ne marchera pas aussi bien cette fois
ci donc c'est plus mon parti je n'ai
tiré les conséquences il doit y avoir
des gens dans le parti ump qui doivent
penser comme bon d'accord alors la
traîtrise où la condamnée est évidemment
philippe douste-blazy françois hollande
aussi qui a eu ce mot contre eric besson
qui lui est passé en 2007 en pleine
campagne on s'en souvient du ps
eh bien nicolas sarkozy le destin de
traîtres vous suit tout une fille qu'est
ce que ce que vous inscrire non ce que
je crois c'est que il ne faut pas un
effet lorsque sonné dans un dom
tout dépend du programme évidemment que
vous avez si demain matin françois
hollande était social démocrate en
disant je ne veux plus entendre parler
de l'extrême gauche
je promets risque il ya 15% d'extrême
gauche au premier tour mais que telle et
feront ce qu'ils voudront mais moins je
ne veux pas entendre parler de ces
mesures les huit cent mille postes
l'extrême gauche qui est dit ça de
françois hollande est encore aujourd'hui
c'est bien jean luc mélenchon a dit
qu'il ne pensait pas qu'il y aurait des
ministres communistes ça devrait vous
rassurer
oui sur le penchant social-démocrate
bruschi mainland ce qui mettait dans
cette affaire c'est celui qui leur était
au second tour et vous m'accorderez que
ce soit plutôt françois hollande que
mélenchon très bien donc je repars je
reprends si françois hollande dit je ne
vois plus je ne veux plus voir extrême
gauche et je me tourne vers les
sociaux-démocrates et les démocrates
sociaux je veux dire il ya toujours une
possibilité d'erreurs au début de la
campagne je crois que françois bayrou et
françois hollande se parler avant la
primaire il a dit c'est c'est de
notoriété publique et donc il y avait la
possibilité de créer ce parti démocrate
je dirais qu'ils existent aux états unis
et qui manque à la france dont on parle
depuis longtemps mais on voit bien que
françois hollande se tournent de plus en
plus depuis la primaire vers la gauche
pure la gauche dure
continuant avec un parti socialiste qui
n'aura pas fait sa mue qui l'a faite aux
jeunes en allemagne qu'elle a faites au
royaume uni avec tony blair à l'époque
et donc à partir de là il ya ce bloc de
gauche d'un côté et puis il va y avoir
dans les mains l'extrême gauche
et puis de l'autre il y a le camp de
droite dans les mains d'extrême droite
et nous avons pensé qu' il fallait à
tout prix expliquer aux français que
devant une crise comme celle là aussi
dur que nous avons bien il n'est pas
possible qu'au parlement dès l'instant
où il y ait un projet de loi la moitié
du parlement où les deux roues le 1/3 du
parlement des systématiquement c'est nul
arrêté parce que ça on peut pas
redresser un pays si vous avez la moitié
contre lors de moitié alors et donc de
tendre il faut faire une union nationale
quand c'est regarder ce que fait mario
monti mais leur élan par nicolas sarkozy
d'une union nationale
je l'avais entendu il l'a évoqué ils
l'avouent fond mais j'ai entendu aussi
récemment dans un discours sur
l'immigration très dur on voit bien
qu'ils essaient de récupérer les voix du
front national
vous ne pouvez pas sur l'union nationale
si vous courez derrière un extrême
vous ne pouvez faire l'union nationale
que dans les gens qui sont modérés qui
soient des rats droite ou à gauche
le tout c'est qu'il soit excellent nommé
qu'est ce qui va se passer franchement
dimanche 1 ils les soutiens de françois
payot vont se diviser et en a qui vont
pencher pour françois hollande
d'autres comme vous sans doute pour
nicolas sarkozy alors il y aura ce vous
serez n'oserez traître à la grande cause
centriste non mais mais mais mais moi je
pense qu'on va tous voté pour françois
bayrou partout
après les séparent du second tour les
sétois vous avez l'air persuadé vous
avez l'air persuadé donc je regarde des
chiffres vous êtes persuadé que vous
êtes personae du résultat de l'élection
vous l'avez dit un instant à propos de
françois hollande
non je croyais pas je faisais pas dit
c'est dire si vous n'êtes pas du tout
dit ça c'est non non non non non pas du
tout je pense que françois hollande
aujourd'hui et de modèles sondages par
rapport à nicolas sarkozy
vous avez souligné que je commence à
causer avait décroché vie donc je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup d'électeurs de droite
peut-être qu'ils peuvent se dire que
dans un deuxième tour puisque nous dit
que tous les sondages que vous ne
montrez pas notre que françois hollande
est battu par françois bayrou au second
tour il peut très bien y avoir dans les
derniers jours 33 soit abordé le sujet
avant dimanche bien sûr c'est normal
mais j'espère que vous ferez
à moins que vous ne fassiez pas
d'émission entre les deux tours sicile
bien sûr bien sûr le président candidat
qui se dit le plus engagé contre la
dette peut-être pour vous rassurer
également rejette pas mal de points qui
sont mis en avant par françois bayrou
par exemple la moralisation de la vie
politique
il estime que ces deux là pas du tout
une priorité des français également la
nomination du ministre de la justice
françois bayrou propose une approbation
aux 3 5e de l'assemblée pour que ce ne
soit pas un choix partisan
est-ce que cela c'est un casus belli
pour vous tout ça c'est très grave je
trouve que le président sarkozy ne
comprennent pas que la moralisation de
la vie politique est probablement une
des grandes causes d abstention des
doutes des suspicions existent sur la
vie politique française j'ai appris que
100 députés depuis de la semaine
nationale sans députés nationaux en sont
devenus avocats d'affaires depuis une
dizaine d'années je veux dire que
attention j'aime étaient une vingtaine
d'années et du 8 ou 9 ans ministre vous
avez des conflits d'intérêts très
rapidement dans une vie politique et
donc il est absolument nécessaire qu'il
n'y ait plus de conflits d'intérêts dans
une vie politique apaisée non corrompus
nous sommes pas dans les meilleures dans
la liste que faut en général
transparancy international sur la
corruption donc attention ça fait partie
des gens des choses importantes
allez on va continuer de cheminer on va
tenter en tous les cas pour comprendre
quels choix finira par s'imposer à
françois bayrou
si les bains est le cinquième homme
dimanche soir comme l'indiquent
aujourd'hui les sondages monsieur douste
blazy
lui même d'ailleurs le reconnaît à les
appels du pied se multiplient alors y
avait les manoeuvres en coulisses on
vous prête d'ailleurs un rôle de
go-between peut-être avec avec l'elysée
pilier également que j'ai vous avait
démenti à merci je vous avais dément il
ajouté bien sûr mais on allait vous
posez la question dans un instant pilier
également les manoeuvres en public et on
voit ça avec muse aussi
tracts à la main ils croient encore au
second tour malgré l'effritement de
françois bayrou dans les sondages ces
militants du modem serre les rangs
derrière leur champion et sa stratégie
d'indépendance
nous on va par là soap et on négocie
rien on est fidèles à nos engagements et
les appels du pied peuvent se multiplier
ils restent persuadés que leur candidat
gardera le cap et sont des jeunes ya
deux comme vous lisiez qui ont à mon
avis un seul but électoraliste autour de
10 % dans les sondages françois bayrou
peut faire pencher la balance au second
tour alors l'opération séduction
s'accélère au ps et surtout à l'ump on
cherche à s'attirer les faveurs du
candidat centriste des ténors de la
majorité n'hésitent pas à lui faire
miroiter matignon pour sceller la
réconciliation
il en a les capacités s'il ya un accord
politique si la victoire peut dépendre
de lui s'il y a des possibilités
d'accord et dans tant que politique
l'objectif de ces déclarations à droite
s'assurer un bon report de voix est
essentielle pour envisager la réélection
du président candidat sur l'ale
centristes de l'ump on veut croire que
la parenthèse solitaire de françois
bayrou peut se refermer
je crois que ça n'est pas parce qu'on
critique un que l'on s'oppose
je regarde les programmes je regarde les
enjeux je regarde les hommes
je regarde leur passé et je sais je sens
que il ya une compatibilité forte entre
le programme de nicolas sarkozy le
programme de françois braud des
convergences sur les propositions
peut-être mais beaucoup moins entre les
deux hommes pendant cinq ans françois
bayrou a violemment critiqué le
président de la république allant
jusqu'à le traiter d'enfant barbare dans
un livre pour ce proche de ségolène
royal qui tend la main aux béarnais le
divorce est donc plus que consommée et
comme il a été un opposant
ferme et intransigeant et et digne sa
place sa place n'est pas avec nicolas
sarkozy
sans rancune le président de la
république lui laisse la porte ouverte
françois bayrou l'a franchira-t-il début
de réponse au soir du premier tour le 22
avril prochain
voilà donc ça me retombe aussi de l'
agence france presse nous a rejoint
bonsoir famille contribution tout de
suite savoir ce que va décider
françois bâillon mais fait des dégâts
décidé d'être second tour puisque en
plus de plaisir je veux pas désagréable
je vais dire on va essayer de sortir du
déni de réalité on va essayer
d'envisager toutes les hypothèses
vous avez parlé à michel d'une surprise
majeure au soir du second tour laquelle
celle qui permettrait comme je dédie un
deuxième partie de phrases de recomposer
le paysage politique français c'est à
dire que je crois qu'on ne peut pas
continuer à avoir les deux grands partis
français qui sont dans les mains des
extrêmes parce que dans ce dans ce dans
cette élection vous apercevez que les
gens votent contre 2/3 si on écoute les
sondages dont nous parlons deux tiers
des électeurs de nicolas sarkozy
souhaite voter contre
rolande et deux tiers des électeurs de
londres veulent de poté contre nicolas
sarkozy quant aux extrêmes ils veulent
voter plus contre le système
y'a pas 15% d'extrême gauche ou
d'extrême droite en france bayrou est le
seul candidat positif le seul candidat à
l'adhésion mais alors c'est ça la
question c'est que je pense que nicolas
que françois bayrou en tout cas si vous
voulez si vous votez pour françois
bayrou vous votez pour quelque chose qui
est assez clair précis et net c'est 100
milliards 50 milliards d'économies c'est
comme milliard de recettes
supplémentaires à l'euro près présentez
vous dites oui vous dit non mais vous
n'allez pas expliqué que vous allez
parce que tout ce qu'on sait pas avec
qui gouverne vous des torrents votre
programme clair et précis non en
attendant le programme mais non mais
attendez de voir comment comment pouvez
vous imaginer donc qu'il soit élu au
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous avez un mois après
des élections législatives
il y aura dans chaque circonscription
une
un candidat qui sera majorité
présidentielle alors c'est vrai là il
faut que vous vous y fassiez il a
certains qui auront été voté par
socialiste et d'autres qui auraient été
au départ ump peut-être ça pourquoi pas
mais à la sortie il ya une majorité
c'est exactement ça la vème république
et il y a une majorité présidentielle
donc françois bayrou aura une majorité
présidentielle alors envisagé toutes les
hypothèses envisageons l'absence de
françois bayrou au second tour votre
dilemme c'est un quinquennat de françois
hollande avec son programme
intenable en termes budgétaires comme
vous l'avez dit ou un nouveau
quinquennat de l'enfant barbare comment
vous trancher mais vous savez d'abord on
l'a dit à plusieurs reprises avec
françois bayrou
on vous répondra entre les deux tours si
jamais nous n'y sommes pas donc vous
pouvez y aller encore dix fois vingt
fois on va essayer d'avancer
voilà ça ne dérange pas mais mais c'est
plutôt pour ce qui nous regarde moi mais
quand même sur le fond il ya des choses
tout à l'heure on en parle avec monsieur
grossiord la moralisation de la vie
politique
pour nous c'est fondamental nous
pensions même nous pensons au printemps
nous pensons même que au premier tour de
l'élection législative
il doit y avoir le référendum un
référendum pour régler définitivement ça
le ps l'ump nous disent depuis 15 ans 20
ans je vais même dis moi dix fois plus
de cumul de mandat avec nous était là
sauf que là ça sera fait par les fonds
sur le principe il est d'abord aimer la
colère d'une interview à la croix est
dit aujourd'hui non mais voilà ça
s'intéressent à envoyer quelque chose
qui était bon temps ensuite on vas y à
la proportionnelle la proportionnelle
combien est-ce que c'est une toute
petite dose comme le président candidat
a dit où est ce que c'est plutôt 20 25%
comme nous aimerions ce sont des choses
comme ça c'est ça aussi la politique la
politique ce n'est pas nous
moi alors j'ai depuis le début je ne
cherche aucun poste dans cette élection
je suis secrétaire général de la nation
huronne warner positive hier gilles
croix de vie politique je vais vous
voulez dire que je les écris plus tôt
dans une rue la tribune du monde moi
c'est vous qui le dites donc s'il faut
le dire vous confirmez
profitez-en pour bien réaffirmer ce soir
votre vie politique est derrière vous
n'était candidat aucun point dans ma vie
politique est totalement devant moi mais
ces dates de nom mais c'est de la vraie
politique de la politique n'est pas
uniquement hexagonal monsieur gros sur
la vraie politique est aussi
international
vous nous avez dit donc que le fait que
le non cumul des mandats figure dans le
programme de françois hollande pourrait
vous rapprocher de françois hollande
j'ai pas dit ça non j'ai dit qu'il y
avait une affaire de programme et que si
on prend l'exemple de la moralisation de
la vie politique je vois que françois
hollande dit oui que dit que la serre
que ziani non des moins importants mais
non sur les autres on va pouvoir par
exemple on fait zéro augmentation zéro
augmentation de budget en valeur pendant
deux ans on va voir qui nous répond oui
qui nous répondons hervé morin qualifié
par françois bayrou dans un livre
d'innocents ministre de la défense mais
c'était en 2008 appelle aujourd'hui
françois qu'il est sur cet appel france
aujourd'hui françois bayrou a voté
nicolas sarkozy alors il a raison il est
minoritaire il est isolé
je ne pense pas que font ceux que hervé
morin soit majoritaire partie mais je ne
sais pas ce que je que je crois c'est
que j'ai fait moi-même ce choix donc
lorsque l'on met en en 2000 2001 2002
j'ai créé l'ump j'ai cru qu'il était
possible en effet mais à ce moment là
alain juppé qui venait du rpr était
devenu très pro-européens et était
devenu très décentralisateur là
aujourd'hui quand j'entends les discours
anti européen telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui du président candidat
je suis étonné qu'un centriste puisque
oms a donné un blanc-seing
je pense qu'une grande discussion sur
l'europe à avoir bien sûr que cette
europe là doit être modifié enfin on
peut pas quand même donné l'impression
par exemple que la france va sortir de
schengen comme ça ce discours
anti-européen du président tandian fait
aussi allusion à sa à sa volonté de
remettre en cause le rôle actuel de la
banque centrale européenne est par
exemple n'en veux qu'ils disent la
banque centrale européenne de continuer
à jouer un rôle donc ça ne me choque pas
mais qu'on puisse dire je
et je vais remettre en cause
l'appartenance de la france à schengen
l'espace schengen comme ça alors qu'on
sait très bien qu'il y à une d'ailleurs
réformes nécessaires et justifiées sur
l'espace schengen actuellement je trouve
que c'est un clin d'oeil aux gens qui
ont voté non à aux différents traités
européens et je trouve que c'est quand
même pas très responsable
là ça vous ça vous ennuie et le fait que
françois hollande ne souhaite renégocier
le traité de stabilité budgétaire du 19
décembre mais rouillé vous mais je mets
sur le compte de un peu le peut-être une
expérience des affaires
peut-être étrangère européenne mais sur
le fond je pense que c'est bon après ce
traité la quittes purement sur les
déficits et sur une certaine austérité
je pense qu'il est bon d'avoir une
seconde phase basé sur la croissance
d'ailleurs jean claude juncker le patron
de l'eurogroupe a dit que sur la grèce
par exemple on avait fait une erreur en
me donnant qu'une austérité qu'un
ministre ont qu'une austérité donc sa
joie par contre on ne peut pas
redemander au pays de re2 de faire un
nouveau traité alors qu'elle en 12
parties avaient leur parlement pour le
ratifier
un mauvais point pour nicolas sarkozy
c'est un schengen un bon point pour
françois hollande sur la volonté de
renégocier lorsqu'il dit que c'était une
de négociations ça c'est pas possible on
peut par reynaud gossier ce traité on
peut ajouter à notre projet immédiat 4
sa wii ou avec une annexe g sur la
balance à l'heure donc entre françois
centriste maintenant mais on a
l'impression que le taux favorables à
françois hollande
quand on fait l'inventaire non vous
écouter vous qui dites ce n'est pas vrai
on essaye programme par programme idées
par idée
et nous allons donc essayer justement
d'influencé comme nous l'avons toujours
fait de la vie politique depuis à vous
avez entendu dans son élan dynamique du
rap a aucune négociation entre deux
tours il l'a dit à jean luc mélenchon
france au volant c'est à prendre ou à
laisser que françois hollande il ya
quelques heures expliqué qu'il allait
augmenter le smic ou de pouce coup de
pouce au smic
il a ajouté en fonction de la croissance
c'est que la situation des entreprises
il faut quand même le faire parce que on
sait très bien que la croissance d'après
ce que j'ai compris ce sera quasiment
raisonnable oui comme perspective non
mais c'est hélas pour les salariés non
bien sûr mais quand il dit on augmente
le smig
il regarde qui regardent en face
mélenchon donc si ils regardent trop
extrême gauche il sera rattrapé en rit
pas par nous il est allé loin de
proposer les 1700 euros 1 sur le saunier
j'espère j'espère ça ce serait vous vous
avez lu le programme 2011 jour là les
choses absolument sidérant nous étions
allés lire je n'étais pas à lille parce
que j'étais cd confrères vous êtes donc
nous nous partageons mais j'étais par
exemple à lyon lundi alors à lille
françois maillot votre candidat a dit
que le temps de la division des
centristes s'achève qu'est ce que cela
signifie que nous allons dans la
prochaine assemblée nationale avoir un
groupe udf avec les actuels centristes
de l'ump ça je crois en effet qu'il faut
tirer les conséquences de cette
droitisation de l'ump qui est peut-être
d'ailleurs d'après les responsables de
l'ump nécessaire ça je ne me regarde pas
mais en tout cas il faut en tirer les
conséquences et donc il faut que le
centre de la vie politique française
puisse se retrouver dans les faits une
structure politique c'est à dire que
jean par exemple en cas de défaite de
nicolas sarkozy jean leonetti pourrait
être l'un des buts est député dans le
même groupe que françois hollande est
très bien géré leonetti
je peux vous assurer qu'il n'ya vraiment
pas différent qui vient de le dire
d'ailleurs l'instant j'ai pas de
différences entre françois bayrou et et
nous et et jean leonetti mois nous avons
été du centre droit moi j'ai toujours
été du son tournoi françois bayrou est
aujourd'hui moi je me suis ni à droite
ni à gauche très bien moi j'ai toujours
été du centre droit et je suis très bien
et françois bayrou
il ya des gens du centre gauche aussi
qui sent très bien françois bayrou dans
un confia des à des journalistes dans
après après le meeting de lille hier que
dans certaines circonscriptions
l'étiquette ump seraient lourdes à
apporter cela veut dire que vous
souhaitez que certains députés ump
actuelle vous rue vous rejoignez dès les
élections législatives adorent mais ça
c'est quoi ça serait dans la perspective
d'une élection de nicolas sarkozy ça
serait encore plus plausible mettez vous
à la place de centristes qui m'a suivi
j'ai de dire ça j'ai fait une erreur ma
femme qui m'a suivi et qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui à l'ump et qui entend parler
de la droite populaire ça ça fait deux
ans que des députés ump voisinent avec
des députés de la droite c'est sa voix
l'assemblée de the national très bien
vous savez une élection présidentielle
c'est la reine de toutes les élections
en france ce sont des gens qui ont été
élus de la circonscription avec des voix
de l'ump c'est quand même difficile
d'aller trahir quelque part ses
électeurs une fois que l'élection
présidentielle est passée et si leur
candidat a perdu
il est évident qu'ils auront un
reclassement s'il ya une offre c'est ce
que françois bayrou l'avait mentionné
par une partie de l'ump qui pourrait
s'allier demain c'est ça avec le front
national en travaillant je veux dire
jallet de l'autre côté c'est une énorme
question c'était énorme question parce
que si c'est ça c'est une catastrophe
c'est à venir puisque grâce en train de
départ comme si tu es un discours sont
déjà là le discours est déjà mère ou le
dis il faut faire très très attrayante
ou en tout cas je pense que marine le
pen la différence de son père serait je
pense oncle un jour à avoir plutôt un
scénario à la bo xi ou fini l'italie
croyais à sa crèmerie révolution l'essai
n'est laissé de se dédiaboliser veut pas
pour moi parce que pour moi le fait par
exemple prend le frais vers sionnel
quelque chose qui a toujours été pour
moi c'est une ligne de conduite depuis
toujours c'était même le premier à
l'époque j'étais du bon coup monsieur
pasqua se poser des questions et j'ai
toujours été très contre au monsieur
gaudin j'ai toujours été très clair pour
moi c'est une ligne jaune qu'il ne faut
jamais franchir jean marie le pen fait
toujours entendre sa voix et votre soin
en marge du meeting de paris au zénith
il a fait le lien
entre les initiales de nicolas sarkozy
et le national-socialisme il a également
fait un parallèle entre le meeting de
dimanche de la concorde et les grands
rassemblements
riscle est rien le nuremberg
je vais dire deux choses la première
c'est une honte
deuxièmement je veux pas en parler plus
parce qu'il a fait ça pour qu'on en
parle aujourd'hui je veux pas lui faire
je peux à lui rendre ce service
pourquoi pour qu'on en parle pour eux
c'est son but depuis toujours quand il
fait ce genre de chose c'est des
provocations pour qu'ensuite parce que
ce que la jeune génération rappelle le
buzz
c'est ce qu'ils cherchent et ça je
trouve ça inadmissible je ne rentrerai
pas là dedans c'est une honte
tout ce que j'ai à dire vous croyez
sincèrement que l'ump peut exploser en
cas en cas de défaite de nicolas sarkozy
je le pense est donc dans ces cas là
françois bayrou accueille les bras
ouverts les brownies et les non dits
centristes égarées aux médias lui il ya
plusieurs personnalités au centre
françois bayrou n'a pas mais c'est vrai
que c'est aujourd'hui lui qui incarne le
plus le courage aujourd'hui
l'intransigeance dont le nombre de
postes de ministres ou de premier
ministre quand on lui a proposé est le
nombre de fois où il a dit non montre à
quel point cet homme a une vision un cap
encourage qui quand même dans la vie
politique française est à saluer deux
dernières questions rappeler de leurs
jours 13 comme d'habitude vous regrettez
que françois hollande et gaz
vous regrettez aujourd'hui que françois
hollande fasse plutôt des appels du pied
vers vers l'extrême gauche est normal
rassembler son camp s'il est élu
président de la république vous espérer
qu'il fasse un appel au centre rassemblé
réunit donc j'essaye de il doit vous
pouvez pas à la fois faire un appel vers
comme vous le dites 'de à l'extrême
gauche pour ensuite c'est bien vers le
centre-ville us à cela du combo que
l'accent soit hollande n'a pas de ligne
vous êtes dur résidence récente se
recentre forcément est-ce que vous avez
vous espérer qu'en cas de victoire de
françois hollande se recentre cajou à
nicolas sarkozy ça peut être son coeur
une dernière question vous plaider pour
le retour à l'équilibré des comptes
publics dès 2016 un petit retour en
arrière quand vous étiez ministre de la
santé que vous avez initié la réforme de
l'assurance maladie en 2004 vous
plaidiez pour 1 re de vous
vous promettiez aux français que
l'assurance maladie la sécu serait à
l'équilibré en 2016
aujourd'hui nous avons 18 milliards de
déficit du régime général de la sécurité
sociale
monsieur douste-blazy c'est pas un peu
illusoire de dire aux français qu'un
jour on va retrouver l'équilibré des
comptes publics quand vous même vous
avez échoué à ramener la selle sur la
sueur et la sécu à léquilibre vous savez
de combien et aimons à l'époque de mon
trop jeune mais douze milliards d'euros
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'avait jamais
fait ça lui personne ne l'a vue
là-dessus et malgré ça ça n'a pas suffi
pourquoi parce que nous n'avons pas fait
je n'ai pas fait les réformes de fond
qui doivent obligatoirement être prises
et en particulier c'est la forme de
fonds c'est sur le financement est sûre
comme il faut qu'on revoie le
financement de la sécurité sociale
obligatoirement d'assurance maladie
merci seigneur que nicolas sarkozy ne
serait pas choqué de la publication des
résultats du premier tour avant 20
heures à 18 heures centre et vous
tutoriaux showcase à choquer ou pas
c'est pas la question
c'est fait alors ce truc on peut dire
qu'il est ennuyeux c'est que si on fait
rester méfiez-vous broccio un an je le
fais pas non si vous monsieur vous lirez
les autres si vous monsieur gros sur
vous faites un sms vous m'envoyer un sms
disant ça vous n'êtes pas la loi ne vous
ennuie pas si par contre vous faites un
tweet à là tout de suite quand vous êtes
en deux temps que je trouve qu'il faut
quand même revoir tout ça moi je pense
avoir la solution c'est que tous les
bureaux de vote ferment à la même minute
à la même seconde comme ça on fait pas
de sondages de sorties parce que
franchement j'étais à lourdes à l'époque
c'était ont voté jusqu'à 18 heures à
toulouse jusqu'à 20 heures
ça permet à des gens comme vous et vous
êtes études et sondages de poser des
questions à ceux qui sortent vainqueurs
d'accord ce serait évidemment une
solution source ils font des sondages
aussi
tout au long de la journée quand elle à
nouveau un bon c'est pas pareil c'est
pas pareil surtout qu'elle est sortie de
l'urd est une chose il dont l'urne ce
n'est bien sûr merci beaucoup c'est un
mur perrine tarneaud de public sénat va
arriver on va d'abord évoqué votre
transhumance à vous douste-blazy reprend
l'expression bah oui mais jamais
abandonné un temps attendait l'idée
celle ci fait que vous avez abandonné un
temps pour venir en france bien plus
grande gloire mondiale que sont bill
clinton et tant d'autres n'est ce pas
tam tran huy depuis 2007 philippe
douste-blazy se consacre à la haute
politique comme il le dit lui-même à la
tête de la fondation united' il fait
baisser le coût des traitements contre
le paludisme le sida ou encore la
tuberculose et facilite l'accès aux
médicaments dans les pays pauvres
bref il combat les grands fléaux de
notre planète et flirte avec les grands
de ce monde
bill clinton ou encore ban ki moon
puisqu'il est également secrétaire
général adjoint de l'onu alors que
diable est-il allé faire dans cette
galère remettre les mains dans le
cambouis de la politique à la française
de la campagne présidentielle
avec tout ce qu'elle compte de chausse
trappes de phrases assassines et
d'appels du pied
il faut dire que françois bayrou son
champion même s'il est passé du statut
de troisième homme de 2007 à celui de 5e
le 2012 restent très courtisées à droite
comme à gauche
soutenir le modem c'est donc pour
philippe douste-blazy une façon de
ressusciter dans la vie politique
française
car s'il a beaucoup existé ces dernières
années sur la scène internationale
l'hexagone l'avait quelque peu oublié
que diable et de vous venu faire dans
cette galère de la campagne
présidentielle
je vais vous dire ça me fait très
plaisir qu'on puisse prendre le temps
pour le dire je n'ai jamais pu le dire
ma vie a totalement basculé en 2006 de
ce que nous avons créé une itt est une
organisation internationale
on va parler dans quelques-uns se basent
y voilà sur un euro par billet d'avion
et les salles présent chirac le
président lula du brésil à l'époque et
ce petit robot billets d'avion on l'a
fait dans 15 pays
on a récolté deux milliards et demi de
dollars et avec ça on soigne par exemple
on va en reparler mais huit enfants sur
10 dans le monde contre le sida
mais non il faut changer d'échelle il
faut continuer à convaincre d'autres
pays pour les billets d'avion taxes les
blues avaient encore du boulot sur la
scène à tanger strain le boulot à
messages et repart tout de suite après
le deuxième tour après le premier pour
le deuxième mais mais il faut changer
d'échelle or j'ai compris que changer
d'échelle c'était la taxe sur les
transactions financières c'est là où est
le fric aujourd'hui c'est là où est
l'argent aujourd'hui
or or c'est pas taxer du tout donc 0,5
pour cent sur les actions mais parce que
personne n'avait notamment pas les
grandes places financières sociales sauf
que nous ne l'avons voté et ça il faut
reconnaître au président sarkozy de
l'avoir fait voter il y à cannes on est
seul on est isolé ce n'est pas grand
chose là me thatcher 84 4 milliards et
demi de livres sterling par an quand
même c'est pas rien
le brésil a fait taiwan l'a fait c'est
très possible nous avons nous montrer
que c'était possible de le faire au
niveau français ce que je pourquoi je
reviens de la vie politique française
parce que premièrement je lis dit
j'avais l'impression d'avoir fait une
erreur en faisant l'ump et donc je
voulais des monnaies mais françois
bayrou c'est lui qui avait raison
donc je suis venu dire je me suis trompé
je t'aide mais la deuxième chose c'est
de dire 'est-ce que tu accepterais c'est
une discussion qu'on a eue tous les deux
de mettre une taxe sur transactions
financières dont la moitié ou 30% pire
et aux pays les plus pauvres et il m'a
dit oui alors je dis aujourd'hui à
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy
s'ils sont au second tour est ce que oui
ou non
moi personnellement c'est capital pour
mon choix donc là ce soir vous les
interpellations les interpelle
totalement est ce que oui ou non ils
sont capables de comprendre que le sujet
numéro un du monde aujourd'hui sur le
plan international c'est que vous avez
un milliard et demi d'agents besoin de
crever sans nourriture sans eau potable
sans accès à la santé à l'éducation à
l'assainissement est bien que
d'interpeller si tard dans la campagne
mais je l'ait fait sauf que ça intéresse
personne la question c'est de savoir
c'est au contact avec les équivalent à
celui de françois hollande assuré bien
sûr ils répondent d'ailleurs les uns et
des autres mais je pense encore entendu
ça à mes côtés comme c'est une élection
présidentielle incroyable moi qui suis
souvent aux états unis ou en chine ou
ailleurs ou d'afrique mais ses gaffes ou
cette élection présidentielle se passe
pour savoir si les gens vont travailler
jusqu'à 60
deux ans et on se fout de qui le sujet
il est pas du tout là le sujet est de
savoir si dans ce 21e siècle il va y
avoir une guerre mondiale ou pas si ce
milliard et demi de gens qui va devenir
trois milliards qui commence à avoir le
le blackberry et internet va savoir
combien vaut un déjeuner à paris vous et
moi un de ces jours combien savent où et
avec cet argent là on peut sauver pour
trois ans du paludisme y auxiliar oui
non mais comme ça au fouquet's ne même
pas aller chercher tout ça alain serge
ces mesures avec 60 euros on peut sauver
pour deux ans tous les enfants du palu
date d'un village pendant trois ans côté
c c'est seulement par exemple ici engagé
sur quels points par rapport à cet axe
alors franchement les financières sont
hollande a dit je regrette que nicolas
sarkozy n'ait pas dit à quoi se devait
servir ce qui est vrai je le regrette
profondément
après nous avoir dit que c'était pour
les pays les plus pauvres deuxièmement
françois hollande a dit à le faire il
faudrait le donner aux pays les plus
pauvres
j'attends maintenant et j'espère pouvoir
travailler un jour avec ses équipes qui
poumons c'est qu'il sait si c'est vrai
mais avec une partie avec une partie qui
doit aller aux pays les plus pauvres
aujourd'hui un enfant meurt toutes les
trois secondes d'une maladie évitable et
curable
on peut pas rester comme ça donc
aujourd'hui les pays des droits de
l'homme c'est la france
est ce que oui ou non on va être les
premiers à mettre en place cette taxe
les transactions financières aux pays en
faveur des pays les plus pauvres
je suis là pour ça vous êtes là pour ça
donc après le second tour de la
présidentielle vous repartez oui vous
avez pas les lâcher en france mais
ailleurs aussi des mots changent on
change tout et si on le fait en france
on le fera dans les autres pays vous
savez pourquoi
la taxe transactions financières
personne n'en voulait pourquoi
maintenant ils en veulent reste que
comme les pays sont dans déficit ça les
intéresse beaucoup
donc ils vont la mettre en place moi je
demande qu au moins la moitié à yop et
les plus bas record et pour finir sur
votre carrière politique nationale donc
vous ne serez pas candidat aux
législatives
non je vous apprécie sa conception comme
me propose là
mais non j'ai décidé cette ut dur pour
moi parfois parce que je fais des
propositions
oui non mais j'ai le virus de la
politique nationale c'est pas toujours
facile pour moi mais j'ai je me suis
astreint à faire ça j'ai une mission je
pense que vous savez quand j'ai été mise
affaires étrangères ce n'était pas moi
c'était un autre c'était aussi bien chez
moi c'est tellement mieux au ministre de
la santé c'est pareil là j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que je suis bien à
mon à mon poste et qu' il fallait un
politique pour faire ça pour faire
avancer les choses elle me touche je
suis d'accord il sort des médecines
walla est donc ça me voulez vous donner
toujours des cours de médecine à paris à
la ribaudière en première année 1 c'est
sarko première est aussi un master et ça
se passe très bien je suis pas trop
chahutée pour l'instant est-ce qu'on a
raison philippe douste-blazy
d'instrumentaliser le vote de jacques
chirac en faveur de françois hollande
pourquoi on instrumentalise cette
accusation nicolas sarkozy là puisque le
clan des chiraquiens gars m'avaient
excepté n'ont déjà que si vote pour
frontier exceed alors merci n'a pas dit
pour qui votre son another l'auteur de
ce mémoire à liberec a confirmé qu'il
n'avait pas fait du moura brésilien il y
a oui c'est moi c'est de lui dont il
prend pas position
d'accord on avait spécialement je n'ai
pas parlé avec jacques chirac je le vois
régulièrement pour lui parler de son
bébé qui s'appelle unitaire mais voilà
et vous croyez sincèrement qu'ils
pourraient voter contre sa famille
politique
sa famille politique laquelle est elle
est ce qu'elle est pas quelle est la
famille politique deux actionnaires rien
droite sans cesse plus tôt que la gauche
la droite française en effet et une
droite aujourd'hui très européenne une
droite tels que mais je veux pas
instrumentaliser
sinon vous êtes à propos de la
moralisation de la vie politique dont
vous avez beaucoup parlé tout à l'heure
philippe douste-blazy est ce que vous
estimez que nicolas sarkozy se bat pour
préserver son immunité présidentielle
comme l'on dit ségolène royal est
aujourd'hui arnaud montebourg ça je
trouve ça
les campagnes électorales sont toujours
basse mais il faut il faut il faut
arrêter sur son de choses que je trouve
ça ne ça donne ça ne grandit pas ceux
qui vous raconter que le socialiste sont
pourris ou que l'ump pourri je pense que
ça fait monter que les extrêmes il vaut
mieux parler des vraies idées alors sur
les idées en tout cas une proposition
françois rebsamen qui préside le groupe
socialiste ici au sénat il veut que la
consommation de cannabis soit non plus
un délit mais une simple contravention à
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
proposition
alors ça c'est un sujet là j'avais
palais en tant que ancien ministre de la
santé de j'ai quitté la loi de 71 est
une loi ou 110 c'est une loi et qui
n'est pas respectée puisque il faut
mettre carrément en présence et pénales
donc
or ça se fait pas puisque vous avez je
crois 40% forme d'une tête d une
génération de jeunes qui ont fumé
donc là il faut certainement revenir
mais pas donner l'impression que tout le
monde sait que la loi est obsolète
elle n'est pas appliquée mais il ne faut
pas donner l'impression d'une
déforestation oui pourquoi parce que
quand vous faites vous prenez trois
commandants de bord d'air france vous
les mettez sur un simulateur airbus
ils voulaient fait poser leurs airbus et
ensuite vous leur faites fumée de joie
et ensuite vous leur faites poser leur
bus il le pose entre 15 et 20 mètres à
droite de la piste ou à gauche donc dire
qu'il ya oui ou non mais voilà donc je
veux dire par là que allez dire que ça
me fait rire au cerveau comme l'alcool
d'air soit d'ici là ceux qui parlent de
l'alcool c'est vrai mais l'idée tout le
monde est content bien sûr on est
d'accord là-dessus semaine qui est un
homme que je respecte beaucoup qui se
nomme de qualité je pense n'a pas voulu
donner un signe de dépénalisation je
crois que s'il dit que la loi il faut
peut-être la refaire ça c'est vraiment
simple ici ça donne je crois qu'il ya de
quoi sarkozy avait proposé la même
journée mais aujourd'hui il trouve cette
proposition irresponsable
une dernière question il ya une
conférence important que ce soir à paris
concernant la syrie ce que vous
reconnaitre reconnaissez à nicolas
sarkozy son volontarisme sur la scène
internationale notamment concernant la
libye aujourd'hui la syrie sur la série
ce qu'il faut c'est agir comme le faire
à juppé c'est à dire dans le cadre et
bien sûr nicolas sarkozy dans le cadre
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
c'est une honte ce qui se passe bachar
el-assad
tu es quelqu'un quand j'étais mise
affaires étrangères que je n'ai jamais
rencontré sur un ordre qui est celui du
président de la république jacques
chirac jamais rencontré cet homme et ne
jamais croire cet homme
voilà les deux choses mais selon l'onu
va suffire ou est-ce qu'il va falloir
intervenir
il va il faudra trouver à tout prix des
casques bleus qui pourrait venir pour au
moins cheminée l'aide humanitaire au
musée toujours sur la diplomatie
oui c'est difficile de faire autrement
aujourd'hui
malgré le peu de résultats le peu de
résultat vu que la russie et la chine
sont toujours contre quelque hoc quoi
qu'on propose sur le plan d'une
véritable punition vis-à-vis de la syrie
la chine et la russie sont contre ce
qu'il dira scandale et de la parole
monsieur poutine
merci philippe douste-blazy d'avoir été
avec nous aujourd'hui pour défendre la
candidature et les valeurs de françois
bayrou
merci à vous bon soir et a très vite